لقد خلط دونالد ترامب في نهاية هذا الأسبوع
بين نيكي هالي ونانسي بيلوسي خلال إحدى
فعاليات الحملة الانتخابية وهو يقول مرارًا وتكرارًا نيكي
هالي عندما كان من الواضح أنه كان يحاول التحدث
عن نانسي بيلوسي والسبب
وسألعبها وبعد ذلك سنصل إلى
هذا الأمر.  تقفز نيكي هالي
في كل هذا كما تقول إن الأمر يصل إلى
ACC العقلي ولياقته العقلية إذا كنت
ستستمع إلى
هذا ولم تقم الصحافة أبدًا بالإبلاغ عن
الحشود التي تعرفها بالمناسبة، لم يبلغوا أبدًا عن
الحشود في 6 يناير، كما تعلم
نيكي هالي نيكي  هالي نيكي هالي، هل
تعلم أنهم دمروا
جميع المعلومات، وجميع
الأدلة، وحذف كل شيء،
ودمروا كل شيء، بسبب
الكثير من الأشياء مثل أن نيكي هالي
مسؤولة عن الأمن الذي قدمناه لأقل من
10000 جندي من الحرس الوطني  لذلك
مهما كانوا يريدون فقد رفضوه، فهم
لا يريدون التحدث عن أن هؤلاء
أشخاص غير شرفاء للغاية. سارة، ترى ذلك وتسمع
ما هو
بصراحة، الأمر هو أن هذا ليس
ظرفًا فريدًا، وهذه ليست
المرة الأولى التي يفعل فيها ترامب  لقد بدا
مرتبكًا نوعًا ما في الحملة الانتخابية وكان لديه
هفوة كهذه، فقد قال شيئًا قبل الآونة
الأخيرة عنه ترشحه ضد
أوباما ومن الواضح أن ذلك لم يحدث أبدًا،
لذا فإن هذا ليس فريدًا وهو
مثير للقلق بعض الشيء وأعتقد
أن نيكي  كانت هيلي على حق في إعلان ذلك،
وكنت أتمنى لو أنها
أثارت هذه الهجمات عاجلاً للتشكيك في
حدة ترامب العقلية لأن هذا
شيء من الواضح أننا رأيناها هي
وغيرها من الجمهوريين مثل ترامب يلاحقون
بايدن بسببه، لكن من الواضح أن ترامب هو أنت
لا تعرف ذلك.  أصغر بكثير من بايدن،
فهو بالتأكيد ليس دجاجًا ربيعيًا ولذا
أعتقد أنه من العدل التشكيك في حدته العقلية
عندما يكون لديك مثل هذه
اللحظات مثل هذه حيث
بدا بالتأكيد مرتبكًا للغاية